alors bon soir bonjour la planète c'est
l'émission tam-tam canada en direct de
mots rien les onze 11 heures locales ici
sur le plancher des ours polaires et ici
en studio vient on a notre famille c'est
la famille s'est tu quand une équipe de
travail comme son copain et à raymond
des marteaux guide avec nos
bonjourbonjour fantastique et puis il ya
aussi marie claude sylvestre
ça c'est ne trouvera maistre française
ya aussi notre webmestre espagnol à lolo
est né dans quel pays à l'argentine
en argentine chose qui se passe en
argentine j'ai appris quelque chose au
sujet de l'argentine cette semaine à lui
à l'émission d' alex trebek donc ce
canadien qui c'est qui est allé vivre
aux états unis que l'expert des jeux du
jeu commence il appelle en anglais
japonais et l'argentine ça vient du mot
argent
c'était priant oui c'est bizarre en fait
parce que celles énoncées pour les rio
de la plata plata cet argent alors
lindry auplata cesser les gens qui
avaient été à côté de buenos aires à
pied à partir des ca de l'argent comme
comme la plata c'était alors la serait
due est quand même là plata ninon sais
pas ce que c'est je sais pas pourquoi
les gens d'al il ya d'ailleurs une chose
qui était drôle ou si c'est quand on a
nommé quatre l'église a nommé les
amériques
on en utiliser le nom bien sûr le prénom
de celui qui suivait la ligue médicaux
ouais mais ricco va s'accrocher mais lui
ce qu'ils voulaient c'était les excuses
y avoir été un orgue est plus exposé
alors écoutez pur c'est difficile de
vous présenter la faire vous qui
connaissez tous je parle de vous tous
évidemment il se présente
devinez le sujet notre émission
aujourd'hui grâce à notre vidéo ça qui
va ajouter aux cinq images vous avez 25
secondes pour me dire c'est le premier
qui dit ce qu'est la bonne réponse suite
est la bonne réponse vous avez la main
ou dit le sujet ces fameux dossier de
facebook en europe avec la boîte qui
rêve qui a utilisé des données pour
ouvrir le cerveau des électeurs
américains et peut-être même canadien
c'est pour ça qu'on en parle de parler
des répercussions ici au canada
et mon dieu j'aime manger un j'aime
j'aime mais peut-être qu'on aime trop
c'est ce qu'on va voir avec des
spécialistes aujourd'hui ils sont comme
ça grâce aux nouvelles technologies
présent à temps
aujourd'hui on est prêt pour le jeu de
la boule avant d'aller vers notre
premier spécialiste
mon ami isolé l'éclairage sais c'est que
c'est notre affaire
alors je vais baisser le ton oui c'est
bien beau un roulement de tambour
quelque chose non en rythme autochtone
je pense ça nous ira mieux
un temps forts et temps faibles
oui comme le cas vous êtes musicien fait
donc moi j'ai pas de rythme alors voici
premier jeu de la grosse boule
aujourd'hui à notre émission il y a dix
huit millions d'abonnés facebook au
canada d'accord je vous donne une partie
de réponse je vous ai aujourd'hui la
suite la question c'est nommer les trois
canadiens sur quatre possède un compte
facebook
voici la question dite moi fin 2017
facebook revendiquait combien d'abonnés
dans le monde
faire le tour de la radio
je cuisinais savoir dans 550 millions
150 millions c'est beaucoup plus que ça
moi je dirais nous visière 900 millions
900 millions et 1 milliard et 2
milliards 2 milliards
mon dieu ici tout on atteint là être 2
milliards au deuxième trimestre dernier
bon ça autour de enfin un peu plus
maintenant de 2,13 milliards 2 milliards
et 130 millions donc mais apparemment ça
diminue au canada ou aux états unis
c'est en chute lorsque les jeunes
participent - vol - être sur le mur
facebook de leurs parents c'est ça
qu'ils disent c'est que facebook c'est
beaucoup plus pour les gens âgés âgées
d'être un des plus en fait
les vieux de 30 et plus utilisent
facebook le reste utilise instagram mai
puis d'autres sautent roja n'y ont pas
droit
en fait je l'espère cas
la plus vieille à 14 il va avoir 15
prochainement mais pas encore c'est pour
ce 15 ans qui va voir sur le premier
content et on sait que chez les latino
américains quand une fille à 15 ans est
une méga fête
exact nous allons annoncer maintenant la
séquence qui va nous permettre de nous
arrimer à l'eau soyouz
c'est très simple mon affaire on va
aller vers skype et on va aller
s'arrimer au point de vue d'un
spécialiste
j'espère que ça va fonctionner bon ben
ça on appelle on laisse jouer la musique
il est là c'est fantastique alors
monsieur thot
est ce que c'est bien comme ça qu'on
pende ans votre nom vous avez un nom
compliqué hein lance je peux pas dire
vous allez pouvoir en fait c'est la tht
comme on dit ce qui met avec un all that
sco la dic au top mais fait c'est
fantastique merci de donner la clé
c'était une clé informatique pour vous
parler aujourd'hui
alors monsieur guillaume latzko toth
êtes professeur au département
d'information de communication
université laval
on a eu le plaisir de vous entendre à
différentes antennes cette semaine pour
parler de ce qui s'était passé dans
cette dans cette histoire de piratage
d'informations d'abord je vais vous
poser la question la pause à tout le
monde aujourd'hui l'émission on va leur
poser ici en studio également et sur le
facebook on ne vous allez encore sur
facebook est tout surpris de cet
événement récent on va l'aider à tiques
écoutez je je suis surpris que ça sorte
si tardivement car ça fait en fait deux
ans que la sphère et déjà éventé en fait
donc donc c'est le fait que ce qu'il ait
fallu attendre tout ce temps pour que
cela
cela attire l'attention qui m'étonne un
peu voilà mais sinon je suis plutôt
agréablement surpris justement que que
la sphère de vienne disons un enjeu de
débat public parce que c'est quand même
quelque chose qui a des ramifications
assez complexe qui n'est pas simple à
vulgariser un dans tous les ressorts en
fait ne sont pas évidents à comprendre
pour un non initié
et je trouve que globalement est en tout
cas dans la couverture médiatique qui en
est faite au québec au canada aux
états-unis en europe
il me semble que l'on m'ait vraiment le
doigt sur les aspects importants et qui
concerne tous les citoyens
mais parmi tous ces aspects donc qui
n'est pas nécessairement facile de
comprendre parce qu'on n'a peut-être pas
le disons l'éducation parce que c'est
une éducation numérique qu'il faut faire
qu'il faut un nom à tous une éducation
par rapport à ça à bâtir en soi est une
notion qui échappe aux gens un aspect
qui pensent encore un peu trop inaperçu
dans cette histoire là qui vient violer
certains dont certains droits en
apparence légitime du simple citoyen du
simple consommateur oui je dirais deux
choses d'abord l'étendue de ce que l'on
peut découvrir sur eux à travers leur
utilisation des médias numériques à leur
insu et deuxième volet la question de
leur consentement à tout ça alors je
m'explique
pour commencer il faut bien comprendre
que en fait on est maintenant capable
avec des algorithmes d'apprentissage
machine on est capable de vous connaître
mieux que vous même c'est à dire qu'on
est capable de connaître un individu par
son comportement
i par ces clics par ces like on est
capable de le connaître avec de
connaître sa personnalité dans les
moindres détails
donc on a maintenant une capacité sans
précédent taillée sur mesure des
messages pour faire résonner ses cordes
sensibles
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui est
assez inédit est par ailleurs lorsque
l'on consent à ce que donnait soit
propriété de facebook et puissent être
utilisés pour nous présenter des
contenus correspondants à nos intérêts
on ne consent pas nécessairement à ce
que les gens puissent nous tentés de
nous influencer politiquement à notre
insu et là je crois qu'il ya vraiment un
enjeu c'est à dire que voilà c'est à
dire qu'en fait on n'en sait pas vrai
qu'on consent à tout ça l'étendue de ce
que l'on veut faire dire au petit clic
lorsque l'on choisit d'installer une
application par exemple en termes de
consentement est très très très étirées
par rapport aux limites raisonnables
parce que les gens devraient et en plus
de ça dans tout processus de
consentement on devrait pouvoir le
retirer
or là actuellement ce qui est ce qui est
en jeu c'est que une fois qu'on a
consenti une fois à a donné à partager
nos informations avec un tiers on dirait
que c'est devenu impossible de suspendre
notre consentement donc il ya bien là un
problème majeur démocratique en fait
l'essence etc et on a commencé les sages
et des réseaux sociaux on a commencé à
être les produits ils nous vendent comme
un paquet oui c'est ça l'histoire
oui oui vous avez tout à fait raison on
en fait nous sommes dans une économie de
l'attention
ça avait commencé avec les médias
traditionnels et médias de masse
traditionnelle ou en fait en particulier
les télévisions privées
en fait ce qu'elles vendent c'est du
temps de cerveau disponible pour
paraphraser cette phrase célèbre enfin
pour la reprendre de l'ancien pdg d'une
chaîne de télévision française
donc c'est du temps de cerveau
disponible
le produit donc bien sûr pour des
clients qui sont ceux qui vendent de qui
ont des choses à vendre que ce soit des
produits de consommation ou que ce soit
des votes mais donc donc effectivement
nous sommes dans une économie de
l'attention et dans ce contexte le le
principe c'est de d'obtenir du temps
d'attention chez les internautes chez
des usagers des médias sociaux il
ce que j'entendais beaucoup cette
semaine la part des spécialistes
s'étaient que vous n'y a pas de solution
facile ce genre d'histoire où les le
problème est complexe
bien sûr cela dit on voit donc les
responsables de facebook qui vont devoir
se présenter au parlement britannique
ici même au canada
on sait qu'il y aura débat falloir qu'il
devait expliquer ce qu'il a fait il a
accepté de le faire
on parle ici du dirigeant de facebook
mark zuckerberg
et puis beaucoup de gens qui disent nous
falloir imposer un cadre réglementaire
détestable com com comme argument mais
quand même il est valable à ses à ces
organismes à ces réseaux sociaux puisque
ce sont des médias peut-être pas aux
séances traditionnelles mais les gens
s'informant beaucoup de gens s'informant
presque exclusivement grâce aux réseaux
sociaux décents la télévision
traditionnelle les médias traditionnels
quelque chose doit être fait pour que
voilà l'argument je laisse trois points
suspension vous voulez rattaché à ça oui
en fait bon actuellement on est dans une
logique en fait de haut de laisser faire
et on est on dit m'a coûté c'est un peu
c'est laisser la responsabilité des
plateformes de s'autoréguler et de
s'assurer que ce que l'on fait avec les
données respecte les droits fondamentaux
des individus
mais en fait le problème c'est que ces
plateformes ont des responsabilités
gigantesque on le voit bien
mais dont elles ne veulent pas tout le
problème est là c'est que en fait elles
ne sont pas intéressés d'avoir ses
responsabilités c'est très embêtant pour
eux c'est très coûteux pour pour l
pardon et donc que ce soit la modération
à des espaces ça a été déjà un enjeu il
n'ya pas y'a pas si longtemps on parlait
de la qualité des discussions et des
problèmes d'intimidation etc et on
disait bon que font les plateformes
alors là ils ont essayé de montrer patte
blanche de montrer qu'elles soient z et
efforts pour mieux pour mieux en fait
police et les peler les conversations
dans les espaces en ligne et là
maintenant on leur demande aussi de
police est davantage ce que leurs
clients font avec les données qu'elles
leur fournissent et un moment donné en
fait c'est en fait ça c'est pas rentable
ce qui est rentable c'est c'est
évidemment de de produire de
l'intelligence entre guillemets à partir
de l'analyse des données des usages et
ça c'est très très rentable mais toutes
les responsabilités qui viennent avec
c'est très très coûteux et donc
actuellement on est on est un peu dans
une situation qui pour l'instant me
semble sans issue
nonobstant le fait que les droits
fondamentaux c'est à géométrie variable
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
selon les états c'est très variable et
droits fondamentaux
oui oui oui norme c'est sûr vous avez
raison que dans des pays autoritaires
non-démocratique forcément fin
évidemment là le problème est peut-être
moins criant les ya aidés les citoyens
qui sont habitués à ce que à ce que
leurs propos en ligne soient épiés voire
censurer
sans qu'il puisse tellement critiqué
cette situation sont peut-être ils ont
moins embêtant pour pour ses plateformes
mais effectivement au canada en france
aux états unis là il a enlacé ça nous
interpelle là parce que parce qu'on est
on est confronté vraiment à une sorte de
rapts de nos deux noms de nos droits de
nos libertés
on est en présence des deux nouveaux
julian assange
parce que lui il a vendu de
l'information en fait il ya donné de
l'information puis un superbe birdie et
attendait de 10 ans
oui dans le cas de julian assange c'est
un peu particulier parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais caché que son
intention était de déstabiliser en fait
un un ordre établi
donc donc en fait de son intention c'est
d'être plutôt la mouche du coche qui
vint par justement par par une
transparence systématique provoqué en
fait de l'insécurité au sein même des
états mais mais là on est on est pas
tout à fait dans la même dynamique avec
avec ses lanceurs d'alert je dirais que
christopher wyld pour moi est davantage
un nouveau cela nous donne dans la
mesure où c'est un repenti c'est
quelqu'un qui était au coeur de ce
système de production de et d' analyse
de données et qui finalement décide des
signes de dénoncer ce système est donc
voilà c'est c'est à mon avis c'est une
affaire tout aussi tout aussi important
que la révélation du programme prisme
paraît devoir d'orgueil alors professeur
on va vous laisser qui est piqueté vous
avez ou de participer à une réunion
numérique qu'une conférence numérique
présentement université du québec à
montréal
oui je suis extrêmement fort numérique
de l'uqam exactement pour présenter
aux travaux de notre groupe de recherche
fantastique merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation aujourd'hui je
vous remercie
au revoir et revoir annonce était le
professeur guillaume latzko teuf teuf de
pro d2 professeur au département
d'information de communication universel
avancée dans la ville de québec on a un
autre invité qui est pressé par le temps
qui doit qu'à rendez vous avec la
télévision nationale de radio canada
salue c'est elle qui doit absolument s'y
rendent dans quelques sites qui on ne
déplace pas la télé alors on va aller
vers lui
dès qu'on ne peut le voici le voilà
alors c'est notre deuxième éviter
monsieur marc-andré léger merci encore
une fois de vous êtes vous prêter au jeu
de la conversation ici est sûre notre
émission que j'aime l'atelier oui c'est
relié au monde de l'informatique votre
atelier fab lab
donc j'ai des imprimantes 3d des
machines outils numériques
attention et la fusée tintin elle qui
est allé sur la lune qui revenue alors
professeur léger vous êtes ça c'est à
l'époque il n'y avait pas encore
d'internet je pense à vous travaillez
les instits sherbrooke vous êtes un
spécialiste des questions de sécurité
alors c'est important de vous parler
aujourd'hui j'aurais vraiment cerner ici
quels ont été les dangers auxquels
seraient toujours les dangers pour les
canadiens qui sont sur facebook on a
bien sûr parlé de ce qui s'est passé aux
états unis dans cette histoire peu peu
d'informations sur les canadiens qu est
ce qu on sait qu est-ce qu on peut leur
dire en fait c'est que comme canadienne
on est intéressé par ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis mais nous on n'a pas été la
cible de la manipulation la de la
campagne électorale de trois peut-être
quelques canadiens qui voient tous et
aux etats unis quand la double
citoyenneté en général non c'est sûr que
nous nous donner ont quand même été
capturé dans ce contexte là donc dans
les 50 millions de fichiers là qu'ils se
retrouvent
chez carbine chanel et skull on a les
fichiers de plusieurs canadiens c'est
assez évident donc on a des données
personnelles on a des données peut-être
qu'on n'a pas envie que circule qui
circulent dans notre précédent a invité
nous disait ça je l' ai entendu
également cette semaine avec 60 j'aime
on peut déterminer qui vous êtes sans
que vous même vous le sachiez
moi j'ai discuté avec ça parce que des
fois je suis sur youtube jeudi gêne pas
du tout la plupart du temps j'aime pas
et c'est parce que bon j'ai pas aimé
l'invité où j'ai pas aimé parce que le
son est mal enregistré où j'ai pas aimé
parce que la durée pas assez longue et à
plusieurs motifs qui m'entraîne à dire
que j'ai pas aimé un particulier un
vidéo une vidéo en particulier sur un
sujet donné et je me dis oh là là ici
d'être un peu trop faim dans l'analyse
moi sur mon impression mais qui connaît
rien ça oui mais en fait c'est ce sont
des spécialistes qui font un petit peu
ce que nous on fait dans la recherche
c'est à dire que nous en cherchons votre
créer des questionneurs on va identifier
des variables et à partir de sons vont
faire des études on va les rencontrer
des gens faire des entrevues des choses
comme ça quand on fait des
questionnaires
c'est très problématique parce que la
marge d'erreur elle est très grande
alors ici imaginez qu'on arrive à faire
des questionnaires auprès de 50 millions
de personnes et on a quand même de
nombreuses variables
c'est vrai que 60 like ça donne quand
même une bonne idée mais là ici on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus que seul
et on va combiner ces données-là de
facebook avec des données de google avec
des données de navigation avec des
données du recensement avec des données
de vos points air mouse ou de vos cartes
de fidélité et là tout cela fait qu'on
peut vraiment très très bien cerner vos
opinions
est ce qu'on peut vous faire changer
d'opinion politique en bout de ligne
ben oui certainement on le vit aux états
unis
on l'a vu avec le brésil la décision
politique comme une décision d'achat
comme beaucoup de décisions dans la vie
on souhaiterait qu'elle soit rationnelle
mais dans les faits
elle est émotionnel ont regardé
l'élection trudeau je m'attaque je nie
pas les qualités de monsieur trudeau
mais la situation et les loges
c'était peut-être pas sur papier la
personne la plus compétente mais c'est
celle qui ont réussi à aller chercher
les opinions qui a polarisé les opinions
comme monsieur thual pas réussi à peser
sur les bons boutons ce sous sol oui ça
viendrait l'opinion oui allez c'est ok
ça vient dire que l'option le vote
politique
ce calcul de la même façon que
qu'acheter une voiture une maison une
paire de jeans tu as we ya quand même
une part la logique à cause du prix de
la voiture ou du prix de la maison alors
que l'on sent pas peut-être aux stars on
ne peut être pas autant d'importance
qu'on donnerait le donnait à le choix
politique il ya monsieur trudeau dont
vous parliez ci est le cas demain il ya
quelques instants il très beau moi j'ai
trois motifs mon affaire alors ils
exagèrent et jeudi il est il a dit il je
pensé hier ou avant-hier qu'il allait
continuer à utiliser facebook durant les
élections
il était très bon à ce jeu d'utilisation
de facebook aux dernières élections
mais qu'est ce qu'ils devraient de quoi
devrait-il se méfier maintenant qu'on
connaît un fait que le pot-aux-roses
volet méconnu
on peut imaginer que certaines de ses
compétiteurs
parce qu'ils sont en compétition pour
notre voie donc certains de ses
compétiteurs peut-être pas tous vont
seront pas très gêné d'utiliser les
techniques comme celles qui ont été
développés par l'équipe de cambridge and
all its core et vont aller chercher à
appuyer sur les bons boutons et c'est
pour ça que ça va être encore on avait
l'impression dans la campagne
une journée 10 est une chose à regret il
l'amène the sont contraires à notre
groupe
en fait c'est pas du tout ça et appuyait
sur les bons boutons avec les bonnes
personnes profitaient du fait que les
gens sont peu informés
donc il était pas
serment conscients de ce qu'ils disent
tout et son contraire mais il savait
appuyer sur les boutons alors c'est
vraiment sur la game qui est à jouer la
peau monsieur trudeau ou pour tout
politicien
évidemment le gros ça reste un art
jovetic le professeur on voit en ce
moment des images qu'on a capté sur le
site web de cette organisation
cambridge à nathalie cas parce que je
n'ai pas vu moi d'image pas vu personne
se rendent là et vous voyez on va
bientôt voir
bon il ya le capitole le capitol hill
c'est très clair pour eux qu'ils ont
effectué un bon coup au plan commercial
de marketing ici avec cette campagne
électorale qu'on a vendu à l'équipe de
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est il ya
plusieurs équipes qu'ils ont acquis et
auquel ils ont donné un coup de main
mais tant pis vraiment en première ligne
sur les images de ce sujet coûte s
j'écoutais ce matin un reportage d'
enquête qui a été fait par une chaîne de
télé britannique
le canot forts et ils sont ils se sont
fait passer pour des clients potentiels
lanka sont allés les rencontrer et le me
liger de carbuccia nous disent que vous
avez pts et nous on travaille avec des
idées déjà les ex-employés du mi5 et mi6
on travaille avec des spécialistes de la
propagande de l'infiltration
on était très loin de la propagande
et comme on peut l'imaginer en allemagne
1942 et 1944
on tombe vraiment dans l'espionnage donc
nos espions qui vont à la retraite
on pourrait trouver un second d'emplois
ces revenus additionnels la fac semaine
certainement bon revenu c'est assez
payant ouais bah écoutez monsieur léger
on va voir tout laisser retourner à
votre fabuleux ce lab c'est très
chouette comme image derrière vous
vraiment il ya d'équipement la donnez
pas votre adresse ses valeurs merci au
revoir
marc andré léger un spécialiste de
sécurité informatique université de choc
bon rien en ce moment et qui doit se
rendre maintenant qu'il vient de
terminer de nous parler il se rend
maintenant à son second rendez vous un
peu moins important d'intelligent
nationale 2 alors pourquoi vous faudra
profiter qu'à ça passe mais merci marie
claude avoir passé ces images du web du
site web en question
sas a ajouté un bon fond de réalité à
notre notre émission c'est pas de la
télévision à la trempe la tige en
réalité galates remplacer sérieux notre
afin d'écouter ses parents sur six est
parti c'est le 202e lancements de jeu de
la boule aujourd'hui à l'émission on
tamise l'éclairage bien sûr voici alors
aujourd'hui c'est que le premier jeu
c'est vraiment qu'il a remportée ça
valait pour 20 points
maintenant pour 30 points 2e manche le
jeu de la grosse boule voit si on
parlait des espions ya un instant la
collecte de données privées
d'internautes de métadonnées qu on
appelait ça des métadonnées dans le
temps où c'était pas trop précis et bien
cette collection à notre insu n'est pas
un phénomène nouveau
le canada a discuté récemment combien de
courriels par jour environ qui sont
écrits par des canadiens
combien de courriels il scrute par jour
une équipe de 2000 personnes au service
de sécurité canadiens dont 1000 qui sont
affectés exclusivement à l'écouté
électronique
deux cent mille deux cent mille courriel
vous dites par jour cinq cent mille cinq
cent mille mais les admins tous vos
courriels ont été lus non
sa traque des courriels la plupart de
mes collègues sont en espagne est là au
moins ils sont en train de donner du
travail à des milices façon voir des
choses alors 400 à 1000 courriels qui
est proche de 6 points pour madame au
jeu deuxième heure
400000 voilà alors on va arrêter les
choses sérieuses on va maintenant aller
vers la question de tam-tam on va
demander à leonardo de livres et la
vidéo qui contient le secret de cette
semaine sur facebook
exilé scandale facebook cambridge
analytique haine ne surprend pas les
experts et vous et vous vous moi nous
sommes sont probables après prisme côte
on est déjà vigiles et on est déjà
observé ça fait longtemps
les télés fort écoute l'histoire c'est
que ça fait trois ou quatre ans mais
c'est sûr qu'au bugs sortait d'un des
entrevues avec son laptop puis les
petites caméras étaient cachés avec une
petite tape
si les messieurs qui est en tête d'une
ressource sur comme facebook qui fait ça
imaginez alors on est tout seul observez
on est tous avec des caméras des ddd de
l'information qui roule pas retour à la
villa marie claude
je ne suis pas surprise non plus moi je
pense que je tape eu depuis longtemps je
suis un peu cynique par rapport aux
médias sociaux puis j'ai aucune vision
je sais très bien que je me le move
comme un livre quand j'utilise ça j'ai
l'impression que je suis une personne
peu influençable c'est une impression
personnelle donc je me dis même s'ils
utilisaient les données pour me faire
voter pour quelqu'un que riendeau mais
sans que ça resterait pas mais
évidemment je dois me tromper mais voilà
j'ai l'impression aussi que j'ai pas des
données si importante que ça même s'ils
ont vraiment sont vides et mon compte de
banque
vraiment ça serait pas un gros chiffre
qui disparaîtrait oui mais jean bart et
avec cette vision là dans l'immédiat se
sauver peach très peu d'accidents le
moment vous n'avez pas la personnalité
de donald remplaçant
vous avez pas les milliards non plus à
écouter raymond vous êtes surpris ou pas
vous vous utilisez vous oui mais sur les
autres
pas du tout twitter un stud pas du tout
d'ailleurs ma fille se paie ma tête mais
régulièrement je ne fais de vingt deux
ans qui se permettent est régulièrement
par rapport à mon téléphone parce que
c'est un téléphone intelligent il moi je
lui réponds comment oses-tu m téléphone
et intelligence en aux mêmes phrases et
il y a je me sers de 7 à paris le pour
appeler d'expo comment ça marche
ouais je sais comment mais quand même
non je n'ai pas d'intérêts à la chose
honnêtement et est en sécurité ce que
maison que je suis très très très juste
quelque chose de très révolutionnaire
c'est ce sont des livres non mais
écoutez les ça fait une heure et demie
j'ai un petit problème avec des gens
j'ai mis une opinion sur facebook lui et
à des gens qui m'a frappé et
gratuitement
puis j'ai décidé de sortir mais pas
facile les comptes facebook mais des
plus participer alors quand l'histoire
dé cambridge analytique ayez sortie moi
je suis allé voir combien des
applications j'avais dans facebook qui
pouvaient retracer mais les informations
que j'ai sur mon sur mon profil
puis j'en avais un vingtaine puis je me
rappelle pas d'avoir accepté ça alors
l'histoire c'est vraiment de faire
attention c'est qui on accepte au pas
quand on partage des choses dans
facebook je sais pas si fermé parce que
si on ferme les comptes facebook
il disparaît pas non plus alors ils
savent déjà ils ont déjà nos
informations ils savent déjà comment on
pense à peu près alors je pense pas que
c'est la solution la solution c'est
essayer d'aider détruit l'allèle
l'édition l'équilibré pour donner puis
pour partager les choses qu'il faut
partager puis pas plus que ça quand on
partage on a un auditeur un internaute
qui se trouve à new york monsieur steven
steven je pense qu'ils nous ont offert
une réaction s'il ya beaucoup de celle
là dedans on écoute je ne suis pas
surpris que facebook ait servi à un
complot à son insu ou non toi la
démocratie dans mon pays mais ce qui me
surprend il me fâche c'est le peu de cas
que font certains médias concernant les
liens entre cette opération de piratage
et des clips de la campagne électorale
de donald trump
il est quand même étonnant qu'on ne
fasse pas plus grand cas du fait que
cambridge hanatika a été fondée par
steve banane ex-directeur de l'est
une campagne de donald reignoux de
l'opération de ces arnaqueurs a été
financée par roberte monsieur généreux
donateurs républicain cette histoire va
devenir plus grosse encore et je
m'étonne de ce qui ne s'était toujours
pas encore mais l'historique et on sait
déjà les mouvements des femmes agressées
sexuellement c'est partout dans le monde
aux etats-unis c'est très fort puis une
des agresseurs ces messieurs trompe
puis on ne peut pas y toucher et là on
sait qui a participé à ça je suis passée
directement je pense moi à l'intérieur
que oui mais ont cependant comme si
c'est vraiment directement mais on va
pas l'avoir non plus c'est l'une des
passants avec les plus de pouvoir dans
le monde
je pense pas qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
quelque chose avec
il a des doigts il ce qui semble coller
lille semble être collée à plusieurs
scandales
mais il n'est fini paris parce que
monsieur téflon le rsa sera
économiquement que ça va faire mal
si la chaîne décide de jouer des muscles
présentement il ya eu une tentative et
yonne c'est la chine décès de par
exemple de mettre des de 15 à 25% des
droits compensatoires et punitifs sur
des importations américaines et le songe
américaine et pencher encore si on
touche on va faire très très mal à la
base électorale de dalkia alors c'est
l'économie stupide toujours d'accord on
va terminer avec celui qui a perdu cinq
milliards de dollars cette semaine sous
peu voilà exactement
voici notre dernière question j'ai
absolument besoin de gagnants cette
semaine s'il vous plaît on tamise
l'éclairage on va faire une émission
comme ça ça va de plus en plus noir n'to
soir comme dans un trou noir nous allons
bientôt disparu ils avaient des effets
spéciaux plus faire disparaître bon
moment et bouge très bien préparer votre
affaire voici la troisième et dernière
question du jeu des grosses boules bon
pour 50 points vous avez 32 20 30 points
et on ne parle pas du reste
ça lui reste la gagne est beaucoup plus
sur x
c'était gagner tout le temps grandeur
d'âme alors voici selon le magazine
forbes sa fortune personnelle à monsieur
zuckerberg
mark elliot de son prénom il est elle
est estimée à combien de milliards de
dollars enfin - les 5 milliards qu'il a
perdu cette semaine une soixantaine
soixantaine et plus et ce en plus de
cinq victoires et je veux dire 40 40
milliards
car bien j'ai fait casser ma voix je
suis un véritable comédien hockey métier
le plus probable
et c'est quoi milhas n'ont pas plus
musiciens proches d'abord c'était ses
choix
40 40 oui et 10 passes en bombe a coûté
jeu j'ai pardonnez-moi personnelles de
plus de 100 milliards ça ça doit être
vous ça mais pas lui alors c'était 60 et
12 min dépasser c'est qu'il ya
maintenant 5e excusé alors écoutez miss
est le plus c'est le deuxième plus jeune
au monde au niveau des milliardaires
il est possédé par un autre spécialiste
et il a quel âge en fait 34 30 mètres en
quatre ans au mois de mai 1 34 eur mois
de mai jusqu'à 14 mai 1984 décidé pour
faire de radio 34 ans c'est jeune c'est
un flou comme déjà chez nous c'est vrai
alors vous allez me l'expliquer parce
qu'il connaît tous d'où vient
l'expression flou il ya des régions pour
les jeunes garçons on appelait ça un
flot hockey les filles c'était swan flow
nous une souche de notre action oui
c'est vrai très mal mais d'où vient
l'expression parlait d'un enfant l'appli
un flou ouais parce qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de mortalité infantile donc
quand un enfant naissait c'en était même
élément d'un fléau
waouh on peut terminer là dessus